okay first of all yes Queen you better
have the highest score well happy
Halloween
it was so good what did you think about
your outfit did you find it restrictive
at all in terms of the performance no
you know what first of all being on this
show and getting custom
Couture looks each week made by our
amazing wardrobe department is like a
gift it's like Christmas to a drag
Entertainer like myself and so to be
able to go out there and and deliver
this number but you know have freedom
honey I'm a drag queen I know how to
work it whether it's in a tablecloth and
a full-on outfit okay Hallelujah
Hallelujah okay
um are you excited to take off this
makeup that's what I want to know I'm so
excited about to take up this week I
have no idea how you do it every single
I know my bottom lash is coming off okay
like oh my baby's bottom left my bottom
lash I have no you got to teach me how
to do it I don't know what you're doing
but I'll let you take this off because
I'm like my head is about to explode me
on the other hand I'm going to the club
oh my god do you have a favorite
Halloween memory
you know my favorite Halloween memory is
getting photos and watching the kids get
dressed up for Halloween I have the most
beautiful nieces and nephews and to
watch them get in their like little
looks like my one of my little nieces
was a cheerleader and I used to be a
cheerleader so like getting her in her
little cheer costume she's seven was the
cutest thing ever and like sending those
pictures around I know he has two
daughters he knows what it's like to see
them all cute yeah trick-or-treating and
dress up and I got my older one at
costume and uh the little one too so
they're going to trick or treat yeah
tonight so fun how were we feeling
physically but also mentally like where
are we at right now
motivated
uh look at this doll the dog maybe
Delirious maybe Doll lyrics
honey that's you Shannon is fired up and
I'm gonna tell you why because we have
been like in this conversation working
so hard and the scores have been
climbing from the judges you know
sometimes we feel like dang they didn't
give us a lot of love but we know we
have worked through I know I didn't come
up here oh I ain't been in class since I
was five I'm nobody's professional
dancer but one thing I love to do is
perform and dance and so glad has been
working really hard with me on like
harnessing the entertainment Showmanship
of it but combining it with the
technique so right now for us to get all
tense today I'm like okay we're getting
better so let's keep going yeah yeah and
lastly is there any rivalry with the
other team now that we have teams
and it was for this episode but is there
a feeling of like rivalry now did it
ignite anything
like you said like Angela said we're all
family but there is still a competition
you know so we work really hard every
single week and there's a little kind of
a competitive tension but like in a good
way because it's so sort of naturally
everyone pushes each other to get better
every week so competition's good baby I
love it we're friends we want to see
each other do well now we want to do the
best but we don't want to see anyone do
bad I love all of my friends who are in
this competition and every week you can
see us up in the balcony and Skybox when
other people are performing we're not in
the bathroom or hanging out in the back
we're out here supporting showing love
because that's what family does
thank you thank you y'all killed it